this is like a hello Clarice kind of
situation today I am trying a base Mack
from the 90s if you like a face mask
from 1999 would be like that slime from
Nickelodeon
maybe that's because like that's what I
would have wanted from a face mask in
1999 I'm nervous because I feel like
it's gonna be super extra and I'm
excited because it's gonna be super
extra let's see what this thing is I'm
kind of nervous I'm gonna like to climb
from the ceiling or something
I stopped
I'm over it I could not oh my god so
scary yeah this looks like I'm bout to
like like I'd love to go rob something
fun fast
Jason was based off of this skin care
product Linda has on a full face of
makeup Linda's face is beep like get
into this you obviously talked about the
complexion I guess this is supposed to
look natural which is even scarier but
this is not my skin oh my god welcome to
my cult ok Linda looks pretty fly she
has my next card the power blazer
I like the soft jazz in the background
that's a nice touch that should not be
comfortable and tight it's definitely
both of those things could you imagine
like waking up next to somebody with
this mask on I would die and putting the
gel on the probes I assume so I don't
get electrocuted
Linda's skin is tight and right she has
not one pore or a fine line however I
don't know if she got all of that from
this mask so I thought might have like a
different face when I take this it's
like dinner the nudity but on my face
that feels like they're starving me with
very tiny little spheres
[Music]
Lisa you are a liar this is a scam
[Music]
Linda me and you have a problem I'm glad
that I tried it I won't be trying every
time I feel like Linda is like that
friend that's like yeah you look great
and then you go out and take all these
pictures and then you see yourself like
on Facebook two years later and you
really looked a mess and you're like
Linda Loki set me up this mask
who knows it might be worth it but you
know all the time it takes to put a
little gel on dots and I it's my first
shoutout to Linda I respect the hustle
it obviously works for her because she
looks amazing but I'll be sticking to my
$2.00 sheet mask if anything like the
90s skincare just proves that like every
generation has its weird thing that
doesn't really make sense for skincare
but they try it because humans are
absurd and are always grasping at you
I'll be curious in like 10 years
what I'll think of the skincare fads now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you